i checked in with the fairway chevrolet
before the big
the big punt for pickup challenge
tomorrow so check this out
terry tomorrow pump for a pickup we're
already there
tomorrow's the day right here at fairway
chevrolet all right so before we talk
about the contest let's talk about
fairway chevrolet
what do you guys offer your customers
well first off trucks are cheaper on
esaher as everybody knows right we like
the sound of that and
and what we offer is great service we
offer
exceptional selection you know from
colorado to silverado to
you know just you name any type of truck
we've got it here fairway chevrolet and
you mentioned service what's your
service department like
our service department's huge i mean
when you come in here we're 17 acres
here we have a huge service department
our people are specialized they
understand trucks
and we just have a great offer great
service and for people that understand
trucks and love trucks
they also love their accessories oh yeah
accessories i hear you guys have some
cool ones we do from wheels and tires to
running boards to
fender flares to lifted vehicles to
lower
you name it we've got it all here you
got it covered and you're giving your
your customers a chance to win big
tomorrow for the pump for a pickup
contest and i hear they have to kick
that ball 40 yards yep 40 yards into the
back of the pickup truck
i want to see where this is happening
well you're gonna need that uh are you
putting me to the test well let's
go and try all right if you can do it
let's go do it okay
let's go let's go okay here we are
that's
that's a long way away what are the
rules here well so here's the rule
you take the football uh-huh you punt it
okay
lands in the back of the pickup truck if
it lands in there
you win the truck it sounds easy but i'm
pretty intimidating i'm better with
basketballs okay so do you have any
techniques for me if i try this you know
i'm not an expert but what i understand
you you kind of hold the ball lengthwise
on a little bit of an angle
okay okay and then it's just simply a
kick
hitting it with the inside of your foot
and uh
you know just straight on kind of a kick
just kick it straight that's that's
that's the goal all right you guys
coming in okay so counting from three so
ready
all right three two one
pretty good that felt good that was good
that was straight
too wow okay so the the idea is to get
it in
in the back of the pickup truck though
just gotta kick out a little bit harder
just a little bit harder
man but that was straight that was
straight that was really good so people
can come down and watch because
obviously that's gonna be entertaining
yeah it's gonna be a lot of fun yeah
absolutely come on down we'll have
plenty of parking here we have some
specials we have some handouts for
people
okay of course we got a lot of a lot of
trucks so come on down check out what we
have
see see if there's something you like
take it home with you perfect way to get
into the big game spirit right
absolutely uh be a lot of fun that for
the game that comes up on sunday
and we're doing this here on saturday at
fairway chevrolet in east sahara so
perfect
i think i want to go again let me grab
it for you all right okay go ahead
sprint terry oh
it's too far you guys saw that kick
wasn't that bad right
all right check out fairway chevrolet on
east sahara for more information just go
to
fairwaychevy.com join us tomorrow